speeches this afternoon talks debate
whatever you want to call it we will
have a two people talked to us on the
issue of whether or not Jim Garrison who
was the New Orleans district attorney
who prosecuted Clay Shaw for the murder
of JFK whether or not Jim come Jim
Garrison was a KGB dupe the first to
speak will be max Holland who is an
editor of who is a contributor to Nation
magazine as you heard earlier today he
has and yesterday he has a book just out
on the Lyndon Johnson's tapes and a book
that has been in gestation for quite
some time on the Warren Commission I now
give you max haw thank you Jim thank you
again for inviting me to appear my
presentation is why Jim Garrison is what
we used to call a communist dupe in the
1950s during the Cold War and I don't
say that very lightly coming from the
Nation magazine I don't have any slides
I'm not really that technically adept so
I'm afraid I can simply hold up my
exhibits and I hope you trust me to read
them accurately now this story begins in
February 1967 coincidentally the rampart
scandal about CIA funding of a whole
host of NGOs breaks virtually
simultaneously which does play a role in
contributing to its credibility
but as far as the garrison aspect goes
on February 17th New Orleans states item
breaks the story that Jim Garrison the
District Attorney of New Orleans Parish
is reinvestigating the assassination of
President Kennedy the significance of
this can't be understated because it is
the first time a duly elected law
enforcement official has picked up the
case since the warren report came out
there's been a lot of criticism of the
warren report but this is the first
elected public official with any
authority to do something on February
22nd David Ferrie dies of a brain
aneurysm
he's variously described as a
co-conspirator or a witness or as
garrison put it one of history's most
important figures and the people and who
are working on the cases many of the
investigators and the lawyers and
Garrison's office see this as an
opportunity to drop the case because
they feel they don't really have
anything but garrison doesn't take the
opportunity to drop the case on March
1st he arrests Clay Shaw which is
roughly equivalent to the District
Attorney of New York erased
arresting Robert Moses the Builder of
New York City Clay Shaw was one of the
best known businessmen in New Orleans he
had helped restore the French Quarter
after the war which is a was a decrepit
slum in the late 40s he was responsible
for building building the International
Trade Center in New Orleans which was
widely copied in cities around the world
including the World Trade Center
eventually in New York City March 4th
three days after Shaw's arrest an
Italian newspaper called PI AZ Serra
published a shocking story and this is
Phase II Sarah says clay Shah arrested
in the Kennedy case was involved in
obscure activities in Rome and it says
he was and this is a picture of a
station
from the chin Tremonti ollie
commercially which is roughly translate
his World Trade Center in Italian that
was a story on the first day and this is
the tenth row serve as a means for the
CIA to introduce funding in Italy now
this is why I mentioned the rampart
scandal because this was in the air at
the time story on March 5th every day
there was a story
the Trent the CMC the Society of Clay
Shaw was involved in American espionage
and on and on and on now of course other
Italian newspapers picked up the story
too but they didn't quite have the same
spin on it this is from Corriere della
Sera which is kind of the New York Times
of Italy it said that Clay Shaw was a
counselor who had a Roman connection but
is there's nothing about it being a CIA
front the similarly ill tempo an Italian
paper mentions that the man arrested in
New Orleans has a Roman connection but
says nothing about it being a CIA front
the only papers that emphasize that
aspect are communist papers or
communists leaning papers this is the
French newspaper humanity clay char
worked in Rome for us espionage services
this is a Greek Communist newspaper
it also reproduces the CMC stationery
it's virtually identical to the original
PI's Ysera story this is a story from
lead of war which is a Canadian paper in
Montreal it quotes Pravda that the CIA
used used clay Shaw who's been accused
of being complicit in the plot to kill
Castro Kennedy
sorry this is Lolita which is the
official organ of the Italian Communist
Party Shah accused in the Kennedy case
worked in Rome for the CIA and of course
where these papers lead Pravda follows
this is the headline in Pravda Clay Shaw
was CIA or is from the CIA and I'll just
read you the lead paragraph to give you
a flavor of all these stories the US
Central Intelligence Agency operating
Italy use the services of Clay Shaw the
man whom the district attorney for New
Orleans has charged with taking part in
the conspiracy which brought about the
assassination of President Kennedy so
this is just a few days after Clay Shaw
is arrested a series of stories for
about a week in March now this is what
jim garrison says in his 1988 memoir
about this allegation our patient
plotting footwork had taught us that
clay Bertrand was actually clay Shaw the
distinguished director of the
International Trade Mart in New Orleans
and a civic leader of note but at the
time I emphasize but at the time 1967 we
had no inkling that clay Shah was much
bigger and more powerful than his New
Orleans persona indicated it was not
until much later well after the short
trial which was in 1969 when it could
have been of any use to us that we
discovered Shaw's extensive
international role as an employee of the
CIA Shaw Secret Life is an agency man in
Rome trying to bring fascism back to
Italy was exposed in articles in the
Italian press which we obtained from
Ralph schoneman secretary to the
philosopher Bertrand Russell who had
been one of the earliest supporters of
our investigation now a lot of my
presentation centers on the fact that
statement is a lie and I brought the
most of my presentation of the exhibits
as to why it is a lie and it
alive because of one contributing factor
there's a multiplicity of evidence
evidentiary sources here is a
translation of the PI AZ Sarah's story
that's in Garrison's papers at the
National Archives now in and of itself
of course it doesn't prove he had the
translation in 1967 there's no date
stamp on it
but I did talk to John Mellon who was
formerly married to Ralph Sherman and
she told me after checking with Ralph
that in fact garrison was told in 1967
by Ralph not in 1969 or afterwards but
in 1967 Ralph Sherman was living in
London at the time he was very good
friends with Giorgio fonti who was the
London correspondent for pi AZ Serra and
he gave Ralph the articles Ralph was a
secretary to Bertrand Russell and Ralph
made sure they got to garrison who he
didn't know but of course he read and
the British press about his
investigation
so there's Ralph's word for it another
document that's very telling is richard
Billings diary now tink Thompson
mentioned working with Richard Billings
I know he's been accused of being a CIA
agent but for the first few months of
the garrison investigation there was an
agreement between life and Garrison and
Billings with it was at his right hand
the whole time this is from his diary
March 16th garrison now entered March
16th so that's about 10 days after the
first phase ysera story garrison now
interested in possible connections
between Shaw and the CIA to Leeds re CIA
tae-won is an article in March issue
humanities supposedly mentions Charles
company work in Italy
well the reference to humanities is to
the French communists paper not pay easy
Sara but it's the same story March 22nd
there's another entry in the Billings
diary story about Shaw and CIA appears
in humanity probably around March 8th
giant has copy now Dateline Rome March
7th from the Italian press it explains
Chartres working
in Rome in the 58 to 60 period which is
exactly the charge in the paisa Sarah
story now that's from the Billings
papers in Georgetown there's also a memo
in the Billings papers from the
time-life correspondent in Rome to
Billings regarding the pi z ser story
first sentence in the first paragraph it
was all started by the leftist daily
PI's ysera
which is famous for these kind of
exploits too colorful in many cases the
rarely proven to be basically wrong the
story has been officially denied by all
ministries spokesmen from defense
Interior Foreign Affairs foreign trade
when I asked them it has been similarly
denied the existence of any liaison
between the CMC and CIA during a
confidential talk based on friendship
trust with top Ministry of interior's
official so here's a time life guy
telling Billings who had the full range
of time life resources at his disposal
while I was working with garrison did
this story is dubious but the real point
I'm trying to make here is a garrison
knew about it in march 67 if he didn't
know about it through these sources and
you have to believe that he reads the
newspapers about his case here's a story
from the New Orleans States item April
1967 mounting evidence linked CIA to
plot probe third the fourth paragraph
even investigations pivotal figure fifty
four-year-old Clay Shaw has had CIA
connections attributed to him Shaw
charged with complicity in Kennedy's
death was linked with the CIA by an
influential Italian newspaper so here's
a newspaper in New Orleans which is
aware of the story I talked to the
reporters who wrote the story two of
them are still alive Rossi Aki told me
that this story about CI complicity was
leaked to them by Garrison's office
here's a copy of a different edition of
the same newspaper in Garrison's file so
presumably clipped it at the
this is his handwriting at the top re
sha and Chen Tremonti le commerciality
here's a page from the Proceedings of
the Orleans Parish grand jury on May
17th 1967 a juror asked this question of
Regis Kennedy who was an FBI agent
brought in to testify under oath mr.
Kennedy did you ever make the statement
to anyone that clay Shah was a CIA
member who worked in Italy in 1958 no
sir a juror is asking this question
about Shaw June 22nd 1967 a letter from
Robert Scheer to another journalist the
Canadian journalist a Canadian
journalist at the bottom of it it says
Jim Jim Garrison this came in while I
was gone there may be some items you
don't already have what does the letter
talk about gentlemen diali commercially
it has the Russian story from here is a
letter from garrison August 67 to
Bertrand Russell he's talking about his
theory of the case above the operative
level insulated and removed to the point
of being very nearly invisible appear to
have been in vigil individuals whose
political orientation can only be
described as neo-nazi which is the gist
of the Kyocera story we regard the
defendant Clay Shaw as being a member of
this group bringing fascism back to
Italy here's a letter from November 67
from garrison to Paris Fleming who is
writing a book about the case which came
out I think just shortly before the
trial thank you for your letter of
October 29 with regard to the Chen
Tremonti Ali commerciality might matter
I enclose a recent article in The
Canadian magazine which may be of
interest
to you so I think one could say in this
in so FAR's cases can be closed that
Garrison lied in his memoir he did know
about the alleged CIA connections of
Clay Shaw in 1967 now the 1969 trial of
Clay Shaw was an abject failure
afterwards however Garrison won the
psychological war and a large reason he
kept fighting it was because of his
belief that Clay Shaw was CIA
the Defiant mood in his camp was
captured in some correspondence between
garrison and Ralf schoneman from 1971
children proposes the strategy that he
believes garrison should use I have
thought about the situation with the
company right now the company being the
CIA one of their primary primary
objectives is to keep you off balance
defensive always on the run from them
and never able to pause sufficiently to
regain the offensive paradoxically by
stopping you from using the courts
against Shaw they have freed you to put
the case into a book now it cannot be
considered sub judice a or prejudicial
to a trial so I just urge intensive
let's get out of book hard and fast
which nails the case against Shaw that
we couldn't get into the courts and of
course he couldn't introduce a newspaper
clipping as evidence in a court of law
it's considered hearsay let's put them
the company on the defensive by blowing
the Shaw case sky-high with a muckraking
book that closes in on the company even
closer now in the years immediately
after the trial as the whole garrison
episode faded from view the paiace Ysera
articles were treated by people who
still believed in garrison as akin to
the Dead Sea Scrolls an inner secret the
inner truth Shaw was a high-ranking CIA
operative in Italy and the newspaper
articles proved it and if you look at
every conceivable citation of that
allegation it's always circular and it
always ends up
when the circle closes at PI AZ Sara
that is the source for that story and it
exists nowhere else let's fast forward
to the late 90s in the early 90s a KGB
archivist named Vasily Metropia defected
to the British he tried to come over to
the CIA but they wouldn't have him he
took a trunk full of documents to the
British and the user published the
secret files of the KGB
these were handwritten notes he had
smuggled out of the KGB archives over a
period of many years he was a secret
dissident this is one of the notes in
1967 Department one of the first chief
Directorate this is the Directorate in
charge of what they call active measures
which is akin to the CIA's covert
activities and includes such things as
disinformation Department one conducted
a series of disinformation operations
aimed at inciting targeted groups to
undertake actions along the lines
required by the KGB
there were also stories emplaced
or implanted in daily newspapers to
support and develop such active measures
taken by the KGB
one such emplacement in New York was
through pi AZ sera
so as a check of that I looked for a New
York publication that published this
allegation and I found it in the
National Guardian which prior to its
demise was a very well-respected on the
Left progressive wheat news weekly not
that much dissimilar from the nation and
then their March 18 1967 issue they said
the Guardian has received reports from
Rome linking char with various
right-wing organizations and individuals
and possibly with the CIA the Guardian
was Rome's correspondent courting from
the Rome daily Pius II Sara reported
that from 61 until 65 Shaw was on the
board of the directors of the 10th Rome
on the alley commerciality
which the paper said was a gauge and
obscure dealings in Rome
so therefore I think a strong prima
facie case exists that this was not just
an erroneous allegation or a false one
but in fact KGB disinformation the
history of KGB efforts to impune the CIA
and the FBI go back to about the first
month after the assassination now let's
go back from the late 90s to the early
90s and the JFK film you could call
Oliver Stone a lot of things but I would
never call him stupid he's a very shrewd
and intelligent man and one thing I
think I understood after reading a book
Oliver Stone's USA was that he
understood that garrison knew this
information in 1967 he figured it out -
he says in the book I tried to make it
clear in the film that garrison knew his
case was weak but continued for various
reasons then he quotes garrison because
I believe stone asked him why did you
keep going after Clay Shaw and what's
the connection between Shaw and the vast
government industrial complex conspiracy
that you posit garrison told him and
this is a quote I didn't know exactly
how Shaw was involved but with Shaw I
grabbed a toehold a toehold on the
conspiracy I wasn't about to let go
because of technicalities for one that's
the end of the quote for one he knew
garrison knew that Shaw was hardly the
innocent he proclaimed himself that he
had strong CIA connections dating back
to the war later now this is where storm
stays in concert with Garrison's memoir
later after the trial
garrison found out from Bertrand
Russell's secretary Ralph schoneman that
Shaw had been a board member of a
company thrown out of Italy for
espionage the CMC so garrison is not
contradicted by stone in this book
however what's interesting is if you
watched the movie because a lot of
people would say the movie is entirely
fictional the only thing it gets
as John Kennedy was assassinated in
Dallas but in the movie approximately 88
minutes into it there's a fictional
scene it has to be fictional because of
course garrison didn't know about the
CMC Shaw connection as he says in his
memoir supposedly but in the movie
there's a confrontation between Shaw and
garrison mr. Shaw this is garrison
speaking this is an Italian newspaper
article saying you are a member of that
board at the chin Tremonti alley
commerciality in Italy that this company
was a creature of the CIA for the
transfer of funds in Italy for illegal
political espionage activities it says
that this company was expelled from
Italy for those activities that's
straight out of PI's ysera and then this
is a I'm quoting now from the screenplay
of the book which was published
separately just to show you how wild
this thing had gotten stone actually
quotes is one of the sources of the
truth of this PI's Ysera story the
executive Intelligence Review now that
might ring a bell it's a Lyndon LaRouche
publication as char's response to
garrison I'm well aware of this asinine
article and I'm thinking very seriously
of suing this rag of a newspaper now I
wish I had made a slide of this or some
mock-up this is a frame from the film
you see it very very briefly it's when
garrison Kevin Costner hands the story
to Tommy Lee Jones Clay Shaw and
interestingly it's in it it's in Italian
but it's actually the French Communist
headline it's not the PI easy Serra
headline I think because it reads a
little easier says clay Shah worked in
Rome for the u.s. espionage services
so what's the bottom line here I believe
garrison was duped into believing that
Clay Shaw was a CIA operative or
whatever else you want to call him I do
believe that it was KGB disinformation
you don't necessarily have to believe
that to believe nevertheless there was a
false allegation what does it show about
garrison himself and the larger
investigation I think that he was it
shows that he was a consummate liar he
would lie about anything if he thought
it suited his purposes it's an indicator
of his modus operandi through the whole
persecution of Clay Shaw that he would
go after a person based on a newspaper
clipping now that wasn't his original
reason for arresting Shaw of course I
could get into that if you'd like but
basically his persecution of him beyond
all reason was based on the clipping it
really amounts to the length you would
go to justify riding a tiger the tiger
being his investigation everybody
believed any da who was rational must
have something he had nothing but he
couldn't get off the tiger thank you
very much
let's see if I can have as much luck
hooking up my own computer as I've had
locking up other people's computers
we'll see how this works any other
geniuses out there want to give me a
hand with us have you much obliged and
see if I can get my mouse to work here
earlier nice another Mouse alright
alright let me just say it the outset
that there are you know people including
John Mellon and other people who I think
could be able to discuss some of the
details of this more fully than I can
I'm not a historian of Jim Garrison I
did take an interest in this subject and
in fact if you do a google search under
the name max Holland an essay I wrote
about him is often the first thing that
comes up on that google search and it's
a lengthy essay in which I try to quote
max in context and an extent so and one
of the things that strikes me about it
are some of the statements that that he
makes that I think are fairly wildly
inaccurate and perhaps one of them is
that it is his view that as he put it
himself and I am essentially quoting
here here that the pace of Serra
articles were the wellspring for
garrisons ultimately thea ultimate
theory of the assassination and that
that Wellspring stemmed from an
assassination plot had it not been for
that
those articles in PS sera now I'm not
going to dispute with max the fact that
garrison in his 1988 book wrote that he
had not heard of the case of Serra
articles until after the trial he did
write that it's in the book this was a
subject of a letter exchanged in the
Nation magazine after Zach Sklar and
Oliver Stone screenwriters for the film
JFK had written in to respond to a
favorable review of max Holland's essay
in which he advances this theory and the
essay is entitled the lie that linked
the CIA to the Kennedy assassination
it's a CIA maintained website you can
find it today I believe it's still there
I haven't checked in last week or two
but I imagine still there but it's a CIA
website and Max Holland wrote this essay
and in the first time that I can that I
think max ever advanced this hypothesis
that it was the case of Serra articles
first and foremost perhaps almost
exclusively but most prominently that
convinced Jim Garrison that the CIA had
been involved in the assassination had
been involved through Clay Shaw and that
clay Shah himself was linked
assassination the first time he
published it was in the Wilson quarterly
spring 2001 and the thing that I found
interesting about this is that max
really magnifies the importance and the
power of this what he assumes is a KGB
deception and I read the quote of all
the legacies of the 1960s none had been
more unambiguously negative than the
American public's a corrosive cynicism
for the federal government
he clearly lays to an outsized extent in
my view the loss of the public's faith
in public institutions on the loss of
faith in the government's solution to
the
of the century and that loss of faith
traces directly to Jim Garrison's
investigation and it pastes error
articles it's pretty breathtaking it
away in any case he's already explaining
the fact that these articles in this
Rome newspaper pays to Sarah were what
led Jim Garrison to believe the CIA was
involved in the assassination and that
they'd been planted in pieces here by
the KGB I needn't repeat that he wrote
in the CIA on the CIA's website
pieciness era successful deception of
Jim Garrison turns out to be a major
reason why many Americans believe at
this date that the CIA was involved in
the assassination of President Kennedy
the deceptions we've heard about here
today regarding the CIA and its
continued nervousness apparently about
the cessation are the sorts of actions
that individuals or organizations
entirely innocent of any involvement
would tend not to be orchestrating but
that's the side of the question in any
case no question three days after Clay
Shaw was arrested he was linked to the
CIA by articles that appeared
NPA's is Sara Holland says that PS acero
was a disguised Soviet propaganda outlet
with well documented involvement in
deceitful matza the Russian term and he
has a source which I'd not seen before
from a Canadian newspaper in which
apparently and I'd like to see the
document myself someone has concluded
that
PACA Sara assaulted known KGB
disinformation on some subject but the
evidence that he provides for the
pedigree of the PA so Sarah's being a
known KGB outlet is the testimony at
this hearing on communists forgeries in
1961 in which there was a single person
testifying who testified to the fact
that the KGB does plant stories false
stories and foreign press including the
piezo Sarah and
that man who's testifying this Richard
Helms Richard Helms this is from his
essay the stuff in yellow is Max Holland
writing the stuff in light blue is
testimony that he is quoting in his
discussion in the essay from Richard
Helms so I'll read it for those of you
the back that can't see it because the
print may be small enough you can't read
it back there
max Holland writes altogether Helms
observed the episode was a quote exempt
excellent example of how the communists
used the false news story unquote to
stunning effect and it had all started
with an Italian newspaper that belonged
quote to a small group of journals
published in the free world but used as
outlets for disguised Soviet propaganda
instead of having this originated Moscow
where everybody would pinpoint it they
planted the story first in Italy and
picked it up from Italy unquote that's
Richard Helms max Holland goes on to say
six years later a grander and more
pernicious concoction originating in the
same newspaper gays as Sarah would go
unexamined unexposed and unchallenged
max is given two sweeping statements he
says everything in the PA sister was a
lie I can imagine there probably many
statements in there that are not alive
but I'll have to get his translation of
it to perhaps point them out to them I'm
sure that that's not true but that was
the unqualified response he wrote to
Zack spar and Oliver Stone in the nation
it turned out the Clay Shaw in fact had
been on the board of directors of CMC in
Rome other the statements may or may not
have been true one of the problems is
trying to find out what is true and what
isn't true about what people who have
had a relationship or thought they had a
relationship with the CIA we're doing in
any case the essay appeared in a website
it was favorably reviewed and I'll get
into that because that's actually quite
interesting in my view in a recognized
did publication Oliver Stone's axe Lara
wrote a response to that publication
which was rejected and so they took out
an advertisement in the nation magazine
where max Holland writes and it is a
contributing editor and and they wrote
that Garrison's book on the trail of the
assassins describes in detail how his
uncovering of various pieces of evidence
actually led him to the conclusion that
the CIA was involved this gradual
process began two days after the
assassination when he questioned David
Ferrie a pilot who fruit flew secret
missions to Cuba for the CIA and trained
Lee Harvey Oswald in a civil air patrol
unit many of you may know that it was
long denied by Warren Laurel loyalists
that clay that a fairy knew Oswald and
John Neumann had a picture of Oswald and
and fairy together that he blew up about
five feet high so you couldn't deny the
fact that they were sitting in the same
Civil Air Patrol unit and so that Warren
loyalists myth was demolished rather
abruptly in any case the point that they
are making here is that it was scarcely
the PA so Sarah's stories that were the
wellspring of his view that the CIA was
involved or the origin of his view that
the CIA was involved or perhaps the sole
source or overpowering influence that
directed him toward the view the CIA was
involved and given what we've heard in
this conference here there continue to
be additional reasons why one might be
suspicious the CIA smoking gun or no but
he's right Mad Max wrote back in
response to this rather spirited letter
or this rather spirited piece by Oliver
Stone's explore that he was quite right
that he'd found then he only referred to
notes from Life magazine apparently
there is abundant other evidence that he
had heard about at that time and and so
clearly he had heard about those charges
shortly after he had arrested Clay Shaw
although he arrested Clay Shaw for the
murder without the evidence of those
articles because those articles were
published after he arrested him but only
three days after and Bill Turner had
called him up because Turner was in the
Plus with garrison and I read this back
to him and we went back and forth he
dictated to me and I read it back to him
and Bill Turner told me about this issue
about what he knew and how important it
was to him at that time he said first of
all Shaw was arrested before the first
article in the series is published in
Italy the second you can't name a single
action Garrison undertook that can be
explained by those articles Garin and I
garrison and I spoke all the time in
those days and I can assure you that
those articles were a peripheral
interest at most
since garrison couldn't cite the stories
in court and since he couldn't afford to
send investigators to Italy to prove the
charges they weren't useful legally
certainly some truth there but did he
lie in his book well you know he was
inaccurate there's no question about
that I'm not gonna deny that you can
prove that and Max has got the evidence
here but Shaw was arrested in 1967 and
the book was published in 1988 and
whether they may or may not have been as
important to him and loomed as large in
his mind as max somehow as divine they
have is not at all clear it's even
possible that by the time he wrote his
book that since they had not played any
role whatsoever in the trial and there
were certainly a lot of other irons in
the fire at the time that he wasn't
thinking very much about them and had
not given them that much thought but
let's go in to the issue of how
important the articles were in his
framing his understanding of the CIA's
involvement in the assassination he gave
an interview to Playboy magazine in the
October 1967 issue now certainly by then
the PA sisters articles had all been out
max has proved right here I think beyond
peradventure a doubt that he had seen
the articles presumably must have if
they were so important to him in forming
his opinion about this must have now
been part of his consciousness that kept
driving him forward and Garrison gave
eight reasons to suspect the CIA in this
playboy interview which was the largest
summation of why he suspected the CIA
was involved in it ever given at that
time and in none of those reasons
include
the CMC PSS era in order to even mention
Clay Shaw in 1967 Garrison wrote a
foreword to hurl Weisberg's book that
was entitled Oswald New Orleans a case
of the conspiracy with the CIA that
that's a pretty good opening to mention
why it is you think the pace of sera
articles might have some issue nothing
was said about his Sarah the CIA or Clay
Shaw the point of driving here is that
the outsized role that max has assumed I
think perhaps wrongly that these
articles had informing his thinking and
and in establishing in his mind the
CIA's role and that ultimately what he's
positing here is a successful KGB
conspiracy and I would argue that in
fact they were not as important as a lot
of other evidence that was on the table
that he had divined himself during the
trial for the reasons that max has
explained and I think he's absolutely
right about this that he did not refer
the pace to Sarah's reports during a
short trial more importantly he didn't
take any information from those articles
and used them as a basis for questioning
Shaw he never asks although he had
worked for the CMC or for the CIA but
that's not that the question was never
asked Shaw's own attorney Dimond asked
him have you ever worked for this
Central Intelligence Agency
no I have not answered Shaw now this is
one of those sorts of CIA answers that
might be true technically but is
certainly not true spiritually he may or
may not have ever gotten a checkbook
from the CIA so in the sense that he did
not get a check and they are not gonna
check and CI but the sense he's not
gonna check may not mean the same thing
that he never worked for them and I want
to thank max for that quote because
that's right there and Shaw and the
other thing I want to thank max for is
in that same essay he is in ours enough
to admit that Richard Helms later said
that Shaw had
an eight-year relationship with the CIA
sending the agency information on thirty
three separate occasions that the CIA
and variably graded as of value and
reliable the view I think that some
people would have is that a successful
businessmen that have international
business or often or in that era
particularly were asked when they would
come back from a you know from an East
Bloc country for in you know well what
did you see what you do and it was sort
of considered the patriotic thing to do
to answer and cooperate with your
government in this way and that in fact
the way it is portrayed by Max in the
essay is that this was more or less an
active patriotism perhaps certainly not
bad I mean it was a lie of sorts but not
fully truthful but nevertheless it was
an act of patriotism on clay Schloss
part the interesting thing is that
Richard Helms was the one that framed
the limits of Shaw's involvement with
the agency and Colin never questions
whether Helms innocent version of the
CIA's arrangement with Shaw was fully
truthful whether he told everything he
knew or whether he had told everything
there was to tell or whether the agency
files that he's seen himself perhaps on
this question are intact or sanitized as
we've learned today and we've known for
many years the Central Intelligence
Agency not only lies to the public lies
to presidents it lies to itself you know
and but apparently max Holland believes
it would not lie to him
well Robert Blake he used to think the
CIA wouldn't lie to him either so the
question is was Jim Garrison duped by
the KGB this essay also turned up in an
article in New Orleans magazine and Bill
Turner former FBI agent who as we all
know is very actively involved with
ramparts magazine has had a strong
interest in this case as well wrote a
long letter which I'd like to quote to
you in full and I think it deserves to
be read into the record the info he
wrote the New Orleans magazine which
published his responses follows
was Jim Garrison duped by the KGB the
answer is no I am a former FBI agent and
the author who assisted garrison in his
JFK assassination probe what Holland
omits is that last April he contacted me
about my calling Garrison's attention to
Italian press reports on Shahs linked to
CIA influence trade organizations what
Holland overlooked is that on March 30th
1967
Betty parrot who is in the same social
circle same social set as FBI agent
Regis Kennedy informed the DA's office
that Kennedy confirmed to her the fact
that Clay Shaw is a former CIA agent who
did some work for the CIA in Italy over
a five-year span who knows parrot could
be long expose but you know she might
not be Holland portrays the Shah trial
is a forest in fact Shaw was indicted by
a grand jury and a judge at a
preliminary hearing he's wrong about
that there wasn't joy one judge the
preliminary hearing that decided that
the evidence should move forward to a
trial there were three judges that
decided on that evidence to hear max
tell it he didn't have a scintilla of
evidence with which to move against him
but apparently a grand jury and three
judges viewed that evidence as enough to
move forward for trial and the three
judges ruled that there was a probable
cause to bring him to trial the jury
found that garrison proved a conspiracy
but did not produce sufficient evidence
to plug Shaw into it lastly while the
trial of Shaw took two years to bring
about and did eventually end in
acquittal the basis for the charges
seems sound and the prosecution thorough
given the extraordinary nature of the
charges in time and that's not Bill
Turner saying that that's counsel
Jonathan black Marvel Select Committee
on assassinations I'll read that to you
again while the trial of Shaw to two
years to bring about and did eventually
in an acquittal the basis for the
charges seemed sound and the prosecution
thorough given the extraordinary nature
of the charges and the time and he goes
on we have reason to believe that Shaw
was heavily involved in the anti-castro
efforts in New Orleans in 1960 and was
possibly one of the high-level planners
of the assassination now max
wants to have very ill feelings toward
Jim Garrison some of those should
perhaps go to Jonathan Blackmore who if
not entirely agreeing with everything
garrison did we're certainly sympathetic
the idea that he had reason to be
suspicious of Clay Shaw and he finishes
up by saying that this is all available
in his book rear view mirror now for
those of you not familiar with it it's a
very well and a good read and fun to
read any case was pays to Sarah the only
reason that garrison had to tie the CA
to the crime of the century well the
agency was by then well-known to have
been responsible for the Box Bay a pig a
fair and of course garrison knew about
that
and he also knew about numerous Oswald
associates and their ties to that
episode and as Phil Melanson had pointed
out in spy saga de Mohrenschildt fairy
Bannister and some of the anti-castro
Cubans or CIA connected these are all
people that Oswald was connected to
nothing to do with Shaw certainly
nothing to do with the stories from P
ASIS Sarah these are stories that
independently tended to tie the
assassination to CIA or might have been
seen as doing so so the holla the
evidence that that Hollin presented in
his essay and I he now has new evidence
I to have to address that but all I can
and all I did address it and this has
been on my response has already been on
the web for a year and a half or so is
Richard Helms 1961 Senate testimony and
there he was talking about a prior set
of articles that Richard Helms held were
evidence of disinformation passed by the
KGB through the PA cecere that as he
exposed them in the Senate hearing
proved that PA Caesarea was a KGB outlet
and it had to do with articles that
apparently tied the CIA to the generals
coup against de Gaulle in France and
this is a smear that grew as the
articles were picked up by it from piezo
Serra and then reported back in Russia
and in France in another place in the
world so the whole thing that Helms was
saying before the Senate committee was
that the SS era had started rumors in
Italy that the United States Central
Intelligence Agency had encouraged the
generals revolt against de Gaulle
linked the CIA to the generals revolt
against Dorota gall smeared the CIA by
suggesting that the CIA had supported
the generals revolt against de Gaulle
and this smear was picked up and passed
around the world and this was the
evidence that Richard Helms gave proving
pas Aceros active involvement in passing
along KGB disinformation it's worth I
think quoting what Richard Helms said
under oath and these are the PA Sarah
passages that Helms told the Senate in
1961 was KGB dissing farmacia quote it
is not by chance that some people in
Paris are accusing the America and
Secret Service headed by Allen Dulles
it's not the Secret Service CIA but it's
an Italian paper and they're referring
the American Secret Service can headed
by Allen Dulles so obviously talking
about CA so it's not by chance that some
people in Paris are accusing the
American Secret Service headed by Allen
Dulles of having participated in the
plot of the for ultra generals
in their revolt against a cabal well
Helms was wrong about the date the story
premiered where it started in about PA
so Sarah - it turns out that a pro
agency well respected author a fellow
named Andrew Tully in a book call of CIA
points out that he reviewed the case
against PA Caesarea that Helms had made
under oath and he said that it turns out
that the rumors about the CIA being
involved in supporting the generals it
actually started circulating in France
on April 22nd the day before the story
ran in Rome so it turns out it weren't
planted in Italy first there accurately
reported by PA cesira
first rumors that it started in France
according to a pro agency source and
Talley also added that the evidence
indicates there that there were in fact
operatives who let their own policies
show and by doing so led the rebels to
believe that the United States would
look favorably upon their adventure so
did the CIA encourage the French
generals well you
you probably never gonna get clarity on
that point but it's clear that even the
New York Times James Reston reported
that the CIA agents have recently been
in touch with the anti Collis generals
had the CIA know made very clear their
firm opposition to the generals one
would imagine they might have been
reluctant to move forward a little
perhaps they would still move forward
more importantly max Holland's magazine
the nation had perhaps the clearest
discussion of where those rumors got
their start and it wasn't in Rome it
wasn't a PA cesira this is written in
the nation here in Paris responsible
persons are still convinced that the
rumors have a solid basis in fact and he
quotes Analects panel Express report in
Paris saying that rebel rebel general
chalette had several meetings with CIA
agents who had told him that to get rid
of de Gaulle would render the free world
a great service and I'm sorry that was
cut off so if Holland is right the PA
cessarich fooled garrison he also
apparently fooled it also apparently
fool expressed the New York Times in the
Nation magazine now during that
testimony I'd like to hold up for you to
show you the sorts of dissident format
sia that max Holland was showing to the
Senate that proved how the KGB had so
Sinha said so corrupted the truth
I'm sorry Holmes had so corrupted the
the truth this is taken right from that
testimony and they have numerous
examples of articles published in the
Foreign Press and he was there holding
forth saying that you know this is
nothing but communist disinformation one
of those articles is and you can see at
the top there it says communist
forgeries page 45 of that report I have
the whole report or anybody wants to see
it although it's terrible copy the
faulty original at the at the documents
library in San Francisco but here it is
an American plot to overthrow Sukarno
CIA is planning to overthrow Sukarno
this in 1961 was communist
disinformation by 1975
it was common knowledge so here you have
a situation where a representative the
Central Intelligence Agency is
presenting as disinformation what turns
out to be much truer than what
but he's we can look at it back on my
laptop because the whole thing expands
into a much larger document yes I
probably wasn't true in 1961 no no I
think it this was an hour older I'll
tell you what I'll open it up on my
laptop here in a minute we can probably
even see the date on this publication
here in any case Helms is not someone
whose truthfulness even under oath even
to the Senate even to presidents is
something that can necessarily be relied
upon Max Holland has great faith and his
truthfulness on the issue of PA C Sarah
is having dis informed about and having
told him the entire truth or perhaps CA
having told him truth about the garrison
business but Helms also told the CIA
this told the Senate the CIA was not
involved in the end a toppling and this
is the headline for the New York Times
that he was fined $2,000 and given a
very firm rebuked by the presiding judge
and a two-year suspended sentence so was
the KGB duped via garrison I'm sorry was
the KGB duped garrison via KGB outlet PA
so Sarah even max Holland's idea when it
first appeared in the Wilson quarterly
in 2001 was kind of interesting story
here's a posting by fellow named John
McAdams which some of you may or may not
know I have the posting in my pocket
here this is from 1999 you can still get
it on the web right now today and he has
the entire thesis that Max Holland
presents about how capab the KGB duped
garrison into posting two years before
max Holland ever wrote about it and did
not mention John McAdams name
but it's sort of a horror cliche I think
than that and I want to thank you for
the expression hoary cliche it's a nice
one Thanks
it's yours here's an article from the
1983 Lobster magazine available with
permission on the web today
accepting communist propaganda at face
value perm index the international trade
in disinformation and here they run this
story that the KGB was behind the false
suggestion that Clay Shaw and from index
and a CMC related and here is from the
lobster magazine article available on
the web right now
originally published in 1983 and Max
Hall it doesn't attribute any of this
great find of his to either John McAdams
and story in 1999 or Steve Doros piece
from 22 years ago 20 81 years ago Clay
Shaw was arrested on March 1st on the
4th the Italian newspaper in Pisa Sara
carried an article on the garrison
inquiry well the article isn't really on
the garrison inquiry at all it's just
mentions him in the headline apparently
does not go into the inquiry but it goes
into what they had found in series
investigated articles that ran out over
six days the importance of those
articles is that the editor said that
they'd been assigned six months before
Holland no where credit's John McAdams
received oral with this discovery PS is
Sarah John Mellon spoke to PSO Sarah's
editors and they said that the P SS
eries six-part stories had nothing to do
with the KGB or the JFK assassination
per se I mean other than the fact they
mentioned that the guy who was arrested
in New Orleans turns out that turned up
on their radar too they say that when
they assigned the story six months
before they'd never heard of Jim
Garrison and they were astonished
although perhaps found it very nice to
be able to put it in a headline that
Shaw might have any connection to the
assassination that showed up three days
before the articles and anybody who has
written a six-piece article will tell
you that it's not pumped out in two or
three days these were six articles
were months into preparation so did
garrison have any reason beside the pace
of sera articles for believing that the
CIA was involved in the assassination
and perhaps for conveying to a lot of
people in the public and convincing
perhaps quite a few of them that that it
was involved he certainly knew about see
Oswald's links to de Mohrenschildt Ferry
banister in the anti-castro Cubans all
CIA related people he knew about Oswald
stint at Atsugi Air Force Base a base
that was run by the CIA he had been
certainly written the introduction to
Harold Weisberg book which I imagine was
in galleys in the early in the late 66th
period in which the issue of the CIA's
involvement was a subtitle of the book
and in fact he wrote an introduction for
it and whether you want to accept many
parrots pretrial revelation and not you
know not ultimately important and of
course in Playboy magazine
he gave eight reasons to suspect the CIA
none of which had any to do with Shaw
from an index CMC or Rome interesting
enough how did dawn Holland sit we see a
website article get into the public's
consciousness this is a very interesting
story perhaps the most interesting one
it draws us right into the nine eleven
issue we haven't drawn any kind of link
to that so I'll draw one no turns out
that Philip Zelikow an editor at foreign
affairs who normally wrote reviews of
books took it upon himself to write a
favorable review of max Holland's essay
on the CIA's website max Holland was
working and works now I believe at the
Miller center in Arlington is it oh you
don't work anywhere but you were working
there then he's working at the Miller
center and so I thought to myself you
know Philip Zelikow
is one of the authors of the Kennedy
tapes a book by zelicah Finlay in which
they wrote in the long afterward that
having to do with the human Missile
Crisis that at several times Kennedy's
is the only voice in the room determined
not to go to war and I thought this guy
sounds like a fairly sensible so I think
you know what I you know what's this
with you know with with him and and in
max hall
so I thought I'd write him a letter and
kind of lay out what I've just laid out
for you so I called up the Foreign
Affairs and when to tell him about this
guy over at the Miller center and I got
him a secretary on the phone and she
says oh mr. Zell call is no longer with
Foreign Affairs
he's been made head of the Miller center
so no he was made head of the Miller
center before that now this draws it
into the nine eleven issue he was excuse
me he was a book review editor for
Foreign Affairs when he was head of the
Miller center but he said he's no longer
with well I'll tell you what she said to
me exactly she said mister Shelikof is
no longer with foreign affairs he's
gotten that he's taken a government job
that's what she said the 9/11 Commission
it was before the 9/11 Commission it was
before the my illusion was even
established okay he said he's been he's
taking the government job he's been made
head of the Miller center that's what
she told me rightly or wrongly in any
case Philip Zelikow is is an interesting
character in that he was worked with the
Bush administration in the transition
team in sandy Barger and the
intelligence people from the outgoing
Clinton administration met with
Condoleezza Rice and some people who
included Philip Zelikow
he was one of the people who was debrief
by the outgoing intelligence people from
Clinton administration 9/11 comes and so
who do they pick to be the executive
director of the 9/11 Commission Phillip
silicon somebody who should have been
under oath before a commission like that
and that gets to John Newman's very
astute point about how these
Commission's often don't succeed in
doing what we as citizens might have a
right to expect they do okay so thank
you very much for your your time and
your indulgence
any questions let me just say I agree
with you that Philip Zelikow should not
have been the executive director the
9/11 Commission and I agree with you
that he got it wrong in his book that he
hadn't heard about the articles but I
think where I do disagree with you is
the fact that it's not clear that they
were the wellspring of the loss of
public faith in public institutions in
this country and that it was the result
of this successful communist conspiracy
that's its taking out a context what I
wrote I'll be happy to reproduce it I do
have it by anybody who wants to see this
on the web I quote him in exten so I'm
concerned that this discussion is
occurring without a discussion of the
documents that were released about clay
Shaw's relationship with the CIA because
as part of the JFK Records release there
were documents released detailing that
relationship and I'm concerned that this
discussion has not covered that which I
think is important information those
documents you want to discuss in my
memory of them I was there the day they
were released and I have copies of them
but my memory is that it detailed a
multi-year relationship in the 1950s in
which Clay Shaw reported to the domestic
contact service which is a service that
interviews people when they come back
from foreign travel but that it went
beyond that in that on at least one
occasion I don't remember there were
more he was clay Shah was asked by the
CIA to make a trip to Europe for the
specific purpose of getting certain
information for the CIA attending a
particular conference and he and
indicated that he could not do that
without getting permission of his board
of directors and
he solicited CIA helping getting
permission of his board of directors to
go and funding of the trip and that was
all arranged and I thought that was a
little more than just a passive
reporting kind of relationship and I am
concerned that the what's in those
documents has not been discussed in your
presentations it has not been because my
presentation was more on the question
did did Garrett was that what convinced
garrison that the CIA was involved in
the assassination and was that solely or
most importantly which was max Holland's
thesis and that was what I was
responding to but I do think that's an
interesting question and I and Holland
it you know to his credit is willing to
acknowledge that there was this
relationship although he does not
discuss the part of it that you
mentioned which is news to me and if
anybody else knows anything about that
I'd certainly welcome them in the
discussion that trip didn't happen he
didn't go to Europe he wasn't paid and
soon after that his relationship as a
context source lapsed that's my
understanding so while there was a
discussion of being tasked I think it
was to chuckle savatya to find out
something I think is about machine tools
and machinery he didn't actually
undertake that but it's your
recollection that he did take the trip I
don't recollect whether he did or he
didn't I know there was discussion of
him being asked to do that and the
relationship was a multi-year maybe
Helms renditions of the documents maybe
correct a 33 separate occasion something
like that it started in 1948 after the
coup in Czechoslovakia when there was a
great deal of concern that that was
similar to the coup in 1938 that led to
World War two and I'm sure I believe had
been an army and risen from an elicited
man to officer rank he was very
patriotic and he traveled widely he was
fluent in Spanish so he voluntarily
entered into a relationship with the CIA
there were tens of thousands of American
businessmen who did this during the Cold
War at the time 48 - you know 56 was
roughly the height of the Cold War and
then there's sort of a thought
so that's what I think explains his
connection to the CIA KGB was behind
this particular story about Shaw my
understanding is that you cited
Elms saying that quarry area was was
used by the KGB but it apparently that
had to do with other stories max did you
say that that metro c'n stated in with
you would you review that core ok when
the metro and book came out it created a
particular furor in Italy because a lot
of the allegations had to do with
prominent Italian newspapers including
pazi Serra mean in the book he talks
about the kind of money that pays you
Sara got so there was sort of a huge
public reaction and they set up what's
their equivalent to a Senate
Intelligence Committee to look into that
and the entire corpus of Metro connotes
having to do with Italy were released
online by this Italian Senate committee
it was published and their equivalent
the Congressional Record and Gary
brought up John McAdams and also Steve
Doral let me say with respect to John
John was the one who directed me to this
story so and I worked very closely he
was the one who got me the assistants in
Italy and as far as Steve Durrell's
article in retrospect I should have
credited for what it did say but at the
time I had trouble with it because it
talks about the international trade and
disinformation says a lot of things that
I believe not to be true or supportable
and also a lobster is a conspiracy
oriented publication you know I might as
well quote Lyndon LaRouche from my
perspective too in order to justify
something so I don't regard it as
reliable but I should have credited them
but it is that article is not terribly
too similar to what you wrote No
it is dissimilar well you can read it I
have in my computer but let me let me go
okay the Italian published about 300
notes this is the only place the raw
material information has come out
because his books were the published
version of what he wanted to say but the
raw and one of those notes says that in
1967 Department one of the KGB planted a
story to further KGB activities and it
was published in New York that's all it
says ok but it doesn't say pieces Sara
it doesn't say sha no it says an Italian
newspaper doesn't just doesn't say sha
or just read to you or in other words to
you what it said so it in no way directs
you toward the CIA sha central mundial
nothing specific it's very very it's not
static gentlemen though it's not very
good evidence that that's what he's
referring to it it's a general statement
as far as I could find the only time
pazi Serra was quoted or whether the few
times was caught in 1967 in the United
States at all was with regard to this
allegation he claims to have had very
wide access to the KGB files and didn't
bring out any files with him he made
notes personal notes and then stuffed
them in his clothing clothing leaving
the building that kind of thing so this
is all based upon the handwritten notes
that he made from reviewing KGB files
and it's a very extensive stated access
to the KGB filing system so well I I'm
not going to say that it's not without
problems not only that the notes are in
Russian so then they were translated in
English before they were prior to
provided by the British service to the
Italian service then yours then it was
translated into Italian but I talked to
Christopher Andrew who worked with
Metropia on the book to get a sense of
how carefully that was done and
they tried to do it very carefully I've
got a question back here no right what
Jim here person then we'll go back there
yeah I'm very curious about your
reliance on Richard Helms my impression
is that his job description was
disinformation why wouldn't you require
corroboration in some details and other
sources before you'd place any credit
and what he said well I think the metro
can document is corroboration in
document is we know very little about it
so far it says nothing about Pierce's
Sara it says nothing about Clay Shaw it
says nothing about garrison the trial in
New Orleans it says nothing I mean it's
pretty the mo truckin book talks about
payaso sara as an outlet for KGB
disinformation on the face of it the the
story seems implausible that this person
over decades squirreled away all of
these records and then I mean maybe he's
much more adept than sandy Berger but
he's certainly apparently got a lot more
out than sandy Berger it seems to me
that you need to have some critical
faculty here too before accepting it on
the basis of a published book well I
don't accept it at face value I did a
fair amount of work trying to validate
its what it said now I said before that
you don't necessarily have to be was KGB
disinformation I mean it was just a lie
the allegation and that's sufficient was
what was the lie here the lie was the
lie is that the CMC was a CIA funded
organization in Italy bit bent upon
getting fascism back how do we know that
that's a lot well try and find out
information about the CMC from the CIA
know where else are we going to find out
except from this out of the State
Department when it was set up newspaper
articles from the Chicago Tribune the
New York Times
the London Sunday times like a lot of
cities Rome was trying to establish
itself as a trade center in the post-war
era and they established a World Trade
Center doesn't preclude the possibility
that it could have been a CIA front or
partially CIA funded there are a lot of
newspapers organization you're going to
make that allegations up to you to
provide the evidence I'm just saying
what troubles me is the lack of any
sufficient evidentiary basis for
reaching the conclusions that you've
reached that it's a lie yeah you're
gonna take the CIA's word at face value
I didn't know but you already do you've
already accused them of lying that it
was a CIA front on the basis of what
accused who of line that was a seedy
piece of Sarah or the case there's no
evidence that it was a CIA front no but
you just said they it was a lie you're
going to make the allegation you have to
provide the but you're the one that's
they call them a liar I didn't and you
want it back away from calling him a
liar then that's fine calling him a liar
because they have no evidence and you
have no evidence that they're I mean
let's put it this way the fact that
we've not seen evidence in the CIA and
suppose you have to provide the
supporting evidence there is no evidence
the CMC was a CIA front there is none if
there is I'd like to see it let me ask
this all right yeah do you do you
concede that Clay Shaw was on the board
of directors of CMC yes okay so at least
when you wrote in there that every
session it's a fact but it usually wrote
in their response to in the Nation
magazine that everything in the CIA in
the PA sister was a lie so at least that
statements not a lot that statement was
made that every allegation noted you
drive you said everything in the PSSI
philosophy I didn't put it as well as I
might my question is to mr. Hollin it's
a quick question and a follow-up were
you familiar with William Eternals
William Turner's article in New Orleans
magazine before you present me here yes
so when you were
before and you read it quote from a
juror to a question to Regis Kennedy
about CIA about Clay Shaw CIA
connections you were aware that Turner
had already said that Betty parrot was
the source for that and yet you're
telling us here that everything garrison
had every CIA allegation connects to
pase Sara but you knew from the Turner
article that that one connects to a
witness and not the Pasay Center
I don't believe what Bill Turner writes
at this point I believe what he wrote in
1967 in fact Gary cited his ramparts
article he neglected to mention that
Turner in his ramparts article about the
garrison case uses the paiace pazi Sara
allegation have you gone in and
investigated whether or not Betty parrot
said what very Benny Paret probably got
that story from the New Orleans state
side I'm like everybody else you know
prop probably is not evidence wasn't
withholding anything I gave you the
spirit of Turner's
he said look there were tons of stuff
coming into our office from all
different sources about this this opened
up a real spigot of stuff that was
pouring in including these articles he
said you know there you cannot
demonstrate that there's anything we did
in the trial or even at we didn't even
frame any questions to Shaw under oath
that could have been derived from
information we got from those articles
and if it had been such an overwhelming
presence in our subconscious and
conscious mind about the role the CIA
and play Shaw's involved with the CIA
and the assassination he said you we
would have at least framed some
questions based on that yeah and finding
the record that we did let me have max
respond and then after that we need to
call it call it quit we're way past our
time well if you read the Billings diary
which i think is the definitive account
of those first few months I think it's
very clear that what the effect of the
pi's Ysera articles was and Garrison's
account of who was responsible wasn't
fixed yet it changed a little more but I
think it's very clear reading the
Billings diary which is a
contemporaneous
source the impact of the articles the
fact that he didn't mention in the trial
means nothing because of course he
couldn't introduce a newspaper article
as evidence but he even mention an
offhand come out in comments to Playboy
magazine in Playboy he wasn't gonna
mention them to anybody it was the
secret Oh big secret okay one last
question I think we're done what I
wanted to find out was you know I read
your article and Wilson quarterly quite
some time ago and one of the things that
struck me was you're talking about an
Italian Conte our Italian leftist
newspaper is asada and the fact that the
KGB used it probably for disinformation
now in studying history one thing we
know is that the Italian Communist Party
was generally very independent they
basically told the Soviet Union to buzz
off you know and the fact that you have
this particular you know was you know
ambience going on over there what I'd
like to know is do you have any more
evidence than what you've said so far
that they were duped as a matter of fact
it's not just garrison is being duped
it's actually the leftist newspaper
that's being duped by the KGB because
the Italian Communist had this this you
know or of Independence and they were
the second-largest communist party in
Europe and the Italians generally didn't
like the Soviets that much anyway I mean
what do you have you're gonna replace
Mussolini with Joseph Stalin give me a
break
well I think you're talking about sort
of the later Italian Communist Party
when euro communism arose and there were
you know it was the most independent
Communist Party of the West European
commerce party that wasn't so true in
the fifties and sixties and as far as
whether the tagging paper was duped
there were two reporters whose names
were on those stories one of them died
and one of them is still alive or was
alive when I was working on this and I
had a research and Italy tried to talk
to him
he repeatedly agreed to meet and then
wouldn't meet and finally wanted money
for a meeting
I wonder that's a final question you
continue saying that the tapes of Oswald
in Mexico City did not survive the
assassination or there's no evidence
they did that only transcripts did are
you still holding to that the area I
came prepared to talk to this no no I
just worked on my book I'm not prepared
to okay alright that concludes this
session we will reconvene at 6:45 the
the dinner the dinner tonight is in the
Delaware room